歡迎收看
李台達人秀的
籌碼教學單元
歌有籌必報
其實今天這一集
我錄得有點擔心
我離小哥是比較遠的
因為小哥現在跟台股
一個玄學的力量走在一起
據說是目前
趙華身邊的達人裡面
唯一還沒有受傷的
那我們還是要先上個警語
因為我們這個單元
它的顏色比較濃稠一點
所以要有心理準備
不喜歡開車的可能要有一點點
避之唯恐不及喜歡開車的趕快來看喲
我們的警語為什麼變成這樣
濃稠 你講濃稠覺得聽起來很怪
太久沒來 所以很濃稠
我現在要離你遠一點
好恐怖喔
我OK的啦
這個聽說有人跟他直播完
手機都掉了
因為本來一開始大家覺得是流量密碼
所以阿格莉不是有最先跟他有在臉書互動嗎
後來阿格莉跟我講說
我跟你講超奇怪的
營收出來再好都不會長了
我不要再跟他互動了
然後我就看到你跟他直播
艾德恩也跟他直播
他也找我直播
對
是他主動來找我
我沒有找到他
我就看到你跟艾德恩
然後艾德恩的手機就掉了
他就掉了
我們那天直播有人的手機也掉了
我這幾天我的手機我都寸步不離神的
很怕掉了
你小心掉別的
掉別的
掉什麼東西
我都忘了今天跟
你看
忘了跟觀眾講主題
今天要教什麼
對
今天教什麼
我今天要教
因為最近的盤不大好啦
所以我們要教這個
主力高檔大賣
好 我跟你講
這不是主力高檔大賣
這叫衰神蠶生
他真的是個
也不能說
他是特別反訊號
我覺得很神奇
真的是玄學
你有沒有玩過大富翁
有有有
你有沒有摔神殘身
摔神會神
你知道嗎
東西會掉
錢財會損失
你知道我之前
我還有在做一個
我有做一檔股票的
動態避險
動態避險是我們有多單有空單
對
多單就是買可轉載的多
那空單就是期貨空單
那我最近我覺得這檔股票跌的有點多了
我就把我的空單回補多一點
因為我覺得他應該還是有機會往上
結果有一天晚上看到他寫
明天生計股看來有機會
我說天啊生計股完蛋了
我的空單是不是不夠多
結果隔天我那一檔
南亞黨股票
發可轉載有四檔的
對
跌停
某某大藥廠
你都知道了
我知道
那天不只他跌停
那天藥差藥也跌停
美差也跌停
我把我所有的空單全部都補了
我就只剩可轉載的多了
跟他拚了
別 我現在都不敢靠近你
可不可以中間拿那個防疫期間的屏幕拿過來一下
還好
還好我還有一點點動害避嫌
我想純作多的
當然有些學員是純作多
純作多那天那天也很傻眼
因為真的很少看到跌停
因為這張股票
之後還要發一塊錢股票鼓勵
還可以跌停
這蠻恐怖的
但是那張股票有沒有主力高檔大賣
我們還是要回到主題
他有主力賣但是沒有到高檔
所以我還好啦 反正我把空單補一補
空單那邊是很漂亮的
可是多單這邊
獲利就大幅的消失
你承認吧
對啦
玄學的力量
玄學的力量 真的是我們還是要尊敬
不過昨天 昨天還不錯啦
昨天看到他說明天想做空軍
就知道今天台語有希望
很神奇啦
所以最近
最近
不管是全學力量還有趨勢的力量
各位手上一定要有這種股票啦
為什麼手上一定要有這種股票空單因為你手上你不能存多單最近這個台股的陷阱我看起來我覺得很恐怖所以我手上都有這種股票的空單
所以最近我都靠這空單
來維持我的勝率
來活下去
只要是存多的
最近都蠻慘的
來看第一個
主力高檔大賣訊號
第一個 主力持續大賣
高檔持續大賣
第二个呢
散户持续大白
还要再加上这一条
对啊
第三呢
几保户数大增
等于散户的人数增加了啦
几保户数嘛
对就是股票呢
都跑到散户的手上去了
是
从大户移到散户
对啊
那这个阻力呢
就跑掉了
我们来看一下
这个之前的案例
之前我们找比较久以前的
好比较久以前的
这是那个高点出现在
像这个高点出现在2021年的
出現在2021年的時候
各位看一下在這個高檔
主力就在賣
主力在賣
那邊坐頭主力賣
那三個賣
計劃付出就一直增加
那這種股票你看
從高檔我們把它還原
還原的意思是說
我們把除千息都算回去
都算回去給他
都還你
叫還原
還原下來呢
各位看從高檔到現在
在足足打三折
三折
不過他以前就是一個
获利不好的公司
题材炒上去
主力卖这个就好危险了
对
所以这种
所以我们讲
我们其实还蛮喜欢找这种股票
来建立波段的空单
在这种巨幅震荡的盘势
它可以保护你
保护你的
因为你多单一定亏损
像最近我有些多单
当然也是亏损
但是就是要靠这种空单来保护
那这家里你看
高档这个筹码转乱
打三折
是
很恐怖
所以大家可以留意
有些真的就是他本來獲利就不好
但是因為題材長得非常高
我覺得他這個兩個加乘效應
主力一旦賣那個就很驚人了
真的
好 接下來呢
也是之前大家很愛這一檔股票
長榮
長榮經歷過的減肢
然後除息
除息還兩次都配蠻多的
所以我們一樣
我們把它全部還原回去
因為他有減值有除息
有的人就不曉得
到底現在的價格到底是在多少
我們把它全部還原回去的話
就是按照目前長榮的股價來看
那麼這個他的高點
上次的高點我記得是233
然後我們把它還原回去的話
那高點的價格應該是241.81
就把全部都還回去
是21.81
包括減的資都還回去
還有除息我都還你
都還
各位看 從21到現在大概100出頭
打了4折
這種高檔也是 常常在高檔主力是大賣
散戶後面就開始撿
散戶在長榮
其實在左邊的我們叫做在爬山的過程中
其實散戶持有長榮的不多
因為會怕
買100賣120大家很怕
做得比較短
這個在山的左邊做很短
在山的右邊做很長
以為自己可以撿便宜
結果越撿越套
以為自己是韓國王
結果韓國王就是選在下山的時候做
那這個各位看
這個高檔下來打試著
也是蠻恐怖的
因為這種股票都是套牢蠻多人的
因為你看 極寶戶數很恐怖喔
極寶戶數最高有到快50萬戶啊
有沒有看到這邊
幾保戶快50萬戶
最近居高不下
那長龍在之前十幾塊的時候
那幾保戶數其實很低啊
大概十幾萬戶
結果高檔反而幾保戶數
大概來到四五十萬戶
所以代表說
現在其實有很多人手上
庫存裡有長龍
來你回去看看你的幾保戶
你的未時間水域裡面有沒有長龍
而且到現在的話
都還是有還蠻多
航粉偶爾會出來
就是還是不能講它負面的東西
還是會有人生氣這樣子
對 我覺得持平而論
因為這邊上來的時候
事實上大股東還記得嗎
董娘高檔解脂
我記得那時候在講這個新聞的時候
航粉是非常生氣的會覺得不能解脂嗎解脂就一定要賣嗎沒有人規定一定要賣好 路下來之後那現在的航粉絲絕對已經修正這麼多了長榮的體質確實有改變
他的帳上進金非常多
但是航運能不能賺到像過去這麼多的錢
我們還是要等景氣循環再回來了
可能在等18年
欸欸欸
我說錯了
可能在等18個月
就這麼講
那個
我們在等下一波疫情
或者是有比較奇怪的那種
奇怪的現象
你看吧 人家說你航山就說你航山吧
我今年長榮出席賺很大
兩天而已 三天
三天 我也是當了四天的航海王好不好
這個是以前曾經的案例
有一些警訊出現大家真的要留意
好的 真的
例如就是不要隨便跟警訊直播
你看這一檔就是跟景遜纏上邊的
我那妹喔
他滿神奇的啊
他說他每次看都對
只要一下單就錯
很神奇耶
他這檔我記得就是買在九幾啊
我猜他一定是怎麼看都對
一下單就錯
對
對 這個很神奇啊
這個我們只能說它
非常的靠近散戶
就是散戶中的散戶
我覺得這一集白交了啦
這一集白交了
你看到這一檔你就知道
什麼都不用去看它臉書就好了
你就看籌碼就好了
籌碼其實在高檔
其實主力就慢慢的轉賣了
那你可以看到在高檔的時候
主力買一超
常常呈現一買一賣
其實這個籌碼呈現一買一賣的
就不好
隔日沖比較像
你的股票都隔日沖在玩
波段都不要玩
波段都走了 就剩下隔日沖
那這種股票 長久下來
長久下來只要一枚量
各位你看一下 它的成交量
這高檔跟低檔
這個看起來大概只剩下50%的量
高檔量都很大
最近開始漸漸量縮 沒有人要玩的
現在沒什麼人要提山羊
我們看籌碼 籌碼事實上是一路的主力轉賣
那閃戶呢
一路接就覺得之前沒買到
之前沒買到嘛
之前沒買到 那現在買
買了之後就套
套就繼續買
繼續買又套
所以我們看幾百戶數
大概也增加了快兩萬戶
滿恐怖的
就是人手一張三陽
你回去看看你庫船是不是有長榮跟三陽
我們為阿格莉莫歪兩秒鐘
好啦 三陽是這樣
我們這樣做教學
我覺得會不會越來越可怕
不會得罪人啊
沒有啦 我們都只是講看圖說故事啦
好不好 我們都沒有講
我又沒跟你講說三藏業績怎麼樣
我也不知道 三藏業績真的很好
我也沒研究啦
好 接下來我們來看協議機
哇 協議機也是個腰股
怎麼上去 怎麼下來
你看在上來的過程中 主力已經狂賣囉
主力狂賣
主力賣的還算早欸
他真的賣很早
主力賣的均價在20塊
他大概也沒想到吧
他沒想到居然可以拉那麼高
因為這檔股票曾經上了某本雜誌
某本雜誌特別推
那就一路漲上來
漲到這裡
各位有看到39.5這邊是漲停板
結果隔天跳空跌停
這天很有趣
這天39.5一堆人去放空
然後被標借
因為做卷差
等於那一天是被軋空了
被軋空
那一堆人做卷差
他沒有卷
沒有無卷放空做卷差
那一般來講做券差隔天都很慘
先賠一個跳空開高
再賠一個借券手續費率可能是7%或幾%
手續費率裡面
這個7%裡面還要再抽10%的
那個借券手續費
所以很恐怖
結果這一檔就隔天跳空跌停
你知道為什麼跌停嗎
因為那天公布營收
它的營收5月份很好
5月份超好
6月份超爛
然後呢 最近又有一個跳空跌停之前
又是超爛
又有公布營收
所以這個我覺得這檔真的很神奇耶
好
第一檔營收很好 然後攻上來
攻上來過程中大家都覺得說未來的營收會更好 結果沒有未來的營收這兩個月都很爛那主力在這邊狂出貨我就覺得這很壞等於是被嗑到最高點的那群人也很倒楣
因為隔天就跌停了
對 隔天就跌停
沒有人開心
對啊
有啦 你這個後面
前面做都很開心
後面做空的很開心
因為最近它也慢慢轉弱了
它就符合主力賣少買急保護身
就是股票又流到這個散貨的手上
而且這個還是主力比較早就賣
可能很多人還會覺得主力賣錯
你現在看你覺得主力賣錯
等到你再回半年後或一年後
反正我們節目都還在
一年後你看看主力賣對不對
這個主力是兆豐某大戶
好 我記得不鏽鋼的華欣你也曾經說過對不對
去年底的時候
其實內部人自己都有在賣
後來股價還賣到60塊去了
還想說是賣錯
現在一回頭賣得還不錯
對 他們有的都是要從後面看來知道
好 所以我們教各位怎麼來找尋高檔錯股
第一個 利用觀禮連線排序
因為高檔錯股通常觀禮連線至少30%
最近的盤比較腰 有很多都在50%以上
那籌碼面我們找這個主力短空的
這個至少這個主力最近都在賣的
那第三個利用籌碼K線來驗證
是不是主力賣超 賣超 極寶數大增
這個還是要用工具啦
還是用工具 比較方便啦
對
再列入自選股觀察
所以我們的找尋方法是這樣
好
那最後來教各位這個HOP
HOP是這樣子
我常常利用這個來做交易
假設第一天反彈紅K超過3%以上
就剛好錯過了
那盤後我們會研究有沒有隔日充
那有的話我們第二天開始
我們就會買盤捷徑
我們模擬交易導工
教各位我們先
我們教學都教各位模擬交易
你模擬交易模擬得很順手
勝率九成九
你就可以下場交易
可是會不會跟剛剛講的一樣
看的時候都對
一下單就錯
那你要去拜拜
要去拜拜
那大盤轉空時
最近大盤有點偏空了
說真的
因為它開步林往下了
對 而且就是跌破季限
所以偏空時
我就會留一些高漲出貨股的空單
陪我走一段
第二個呢
假如又有大量隔衝大買的話
假設你第二天空貝嘎了
貝嘎了我覺得你可以留下來
那你看看是不是還是有大量隔衝
那假如有的話
你隔天再空一次
好
那第三呢 你假如是短空的話
你要設停損啦
因為高昂錯股也不一定每一檔都會跌啦
設停損 那遇到漲停板呢
我們是一律會停損
那什麼股票呢
他會從高昂錯股的名單給移除呢
第一個 籌碼轉成主頭買
變主力買投信買
第二個 近期有波段單主力進去
第三個最重要 創新高
只要一創新高 他就不是高昂錯股
因為剛好錯誤股它都是有個三頂出現
那你在創新高那代表三頂沒出現
可能還有下一個三頂
所以剛好錯誤股的我們交易的方法就這樣
好 所以這邊小哥也是要提醒啦
因為股市漲上來以後
很多的提台股大量的震盪喔
如果它已經漲到一個波段的高點
然後主力又很明顯在出貨的話
至少你不做空
你可能也要適度的減嘛
當然主力在賣的時候
不見得是股洽的最高點喔
這點一定要記住喔
所以小哥才會提醒
假設您是比較積極的
您是比較積極的
您希望要做空
可是那你停損也要設好
因為不見得主力一下車
股價就見高
當然如果想要學更進階的知識
就要來到我們的榮耀班
這邊趙華再度的提醒
因為古早以前
我們有一個100塊錢的金銀班
事實上早就沒有再更新了
我們將會在9月1號
把它徹底的關掉
避免觀眾誤定
9月1號就沒有100塊的金銀班
我會把它全部關掉
但是訂榮耀班的朋友們
我們會把金銀班
搬到榮耀班去讓您欣賞喔
所以記得要訂對喔
要訂的是300元的榮耀班喔